[Music] citizens of the reject Nation I am
very excited to be watching this with Johnny
Boy over here who I know is as an Enthusiast I
am for he even brought his Blu signed Blu-ray
to demonstrate sign W this smudge is Edgar
right smudge smug is what I would say ladies
and gentlemen we're going to watch Scott PM
takes off I haven't even seen the trailer for
this but I heard original cast is returning
animated to look a little bit more apt to its
comic book property I cannot wait to see what's
going on people go ahead leave a like like that
button subscribe and click that notification
Bell cuz you best bet that we are going to
be covering the rest of this series also if
you did not catch my movie reaction that did
right here on this channel that is up here on
this channel that's the sentence and as always
full length rtion watch Longs where you syn up
with your own copy available for our super sexy
rejects over at our patreon page John and Greg
that's us cover several things exclusively over
there with highlights and watch alongs included
with this being the first episode though this is
made public the watch along for everyone so if
you want to get a taste of what that's like go
ahead check it out Link in the description
box all righty guys let's get our groove
on o la la
okay cool that's what I like to see
nice it's like an authentic anime
op this is so exciting yeah that's cool to
see it in the actual with the combination
of both I love that this property has
a very inclusive you know love of both
versions they said they wouldn't
do it like if they couldn't get
everybody ett said on Twitter go in blind
and what we're doing doing just that written
by Brian Leo M it's a manga I guess you you
would call it that yeah it's presented in that
style the dream world the sands of
time that's neat I'm so whoa
alone alone precious little
life here she come wow there's
such a vision to this whoa
Yes W the scope on these
shots my God Ramona Flowers
the girl of my dreams it's time to wake up dude
wow what a trip I had a dream about
that girl again he just woke [Music]
up so specific when are you getting your
own place anime angles could you at least
get your own stuff I have a stuff Wallace
looks kind of like asro boy oo can I have
some some of my wow what a great reversal
so leave I was just about to anyway I love
how it feels like a classic dub anime Toronto
Canada not too long ago who's the voice this
time oh I'm excited to see how the
music visuals are brought to life
we hey
hey that's right the movie
had the opening credits with
this Steven I wonder who's on
the music this time more on that
later SL
Bas oh it looks like 3D want to do it again
let's do it again it's cool how they're doing
the focus like how they're representing the
depth of field with the different lines in
animation it's interesting because it's a
kinetic world but because it's a show is
actually able to Pace itself slower yeah
I know sort of my girlfriend Scott your
life is so interesting thanks Kim great camera
work that was sarcasm it's okay I fell for it
too
Scott seems more optimistic
little less listless and
depressed gorill of beard
dreams unknown unkknown she might be
real POV hey hi
you know Sonic the Hedgehog so wide ey there were
two different Sonic cartoons airing at the same
time one was dark and dramatic the other was a
hilarious comedy about chili dogs just staring
off at space the same guy playing two different
versions of the same guy that's a meta [__]
maybe you didn't watch cartoons or or you're not
into chili dogs oh I mostly watched older stuff
when I was a kid Columbo reruns reruns cool got
it did you just ask me if I was real uh no I was
talking to someone else Bye accentuated by the
robotic sound effect there were no plus ones
everyone here is someone I invited personally
she think Scott sucks so do you know this one
girl with hair like this Ramona Flowers she's
from New York City the big app his eyes are
just tiling she's single got a job delivering
DVDs for Netflix DVDs not much longer I forbid
you from dating her Scott Pilgrim cool thanks
Julie [Laughter] bye Wallace quick what movie
should I rent yes something starring a hot guy
oh there's got to be a Netflix genre for hot
guys Lucas Lee best chest in the business
who Chris P uh Chris P yeah oh the game is
over too it's over a second time Evans took
me forever to get there how long could it
take So Meta Netflix they were pretty fast back in
the day oh this must be at the beginning
wow actually experiencing the passage of
[Music] time Sonic guy Wallace
Wells Scott Pilgrim Wallace is
my cool gay roommate so like a sugar daddy
situation yes sugar what enjoy your DVD Mr
Wells bit with a crow are you the person in my
dreams I thought we went over this already he
actually seems like so much more innocent there's
just a really convenient Subspace Highway running
through your head it's like 3 miles in 15 seconds
space Subways totally I get it anyway want to go
out sometime oh could be a lowkey team up Canada
and America joining forces what do you think huh
actually feeling the romance more too here
I like the sort of ethereal chill Wave Music
feels sweeter it's probably cuz all those focus
on knives Chow prior yes and now she's in high
school what's with the X anyway oh this X-Men one
of us went to Professor Xavier's School for gifted
youngsters and one of us did not yeah is that a
Sonic thing is it Sonic no his eyes are smaller
you don't have the same fandoms why' you moved
to Toronto well I got the job delivering DVDs for
Netflix and Gideon always said Toronto was one of
the great cities Gideon what a very specific job
yes what do you do well my last job is a really
long story filled with size how slow the snow
falls we don't have to talk about our pasts it's
my least favorite subject God look at the textures
too I love how they actually look like kids but
they got these adult voices yeah in True Hollywood
fashion I grew up in the mountains man did you
do a lot of skiing no not really yeah it's true
their voices are lower than in the movie uhoh
oh we're breaking perspective man dark bring me
Matthew Patel the game has begun o that's a change
yeah or more accurate to its original material I
don't know this really picked up freezing Rona I
can't see you there should be a door around here
whoa yes into the cosmos oh what a great
transition to her eyes whoa good thing this
wasn't a real date otherwise it would qualify as
a major disaster I'll make us some tea sleepy time
you look like you're dying even though their
voices are older it still matches so perfectly
with the animation counterparts even though
they don't look like they're liveaction coun
just shows how perfectly cast they are and their
chemistry playing off each other even just in
voice yes that's what I tune in for ah sorry I'm
just cold and innocent does
this help oh oh I'm cold too
oh oh leveling up and up and up and up Sparks
uhhuh achievement unlocked were you just going
to bring the blanket from your bed maybe we
could both get under it while it's on the bed
I changed my mind from what to what I'm not going
to send you home in a snowstorm or anything you
can sleep in my bed oh I reserve the right to
change my mind about the sex later it's like a
no warish feel now fatal and it's much more like
straight about these things I really love the tone
of you sent for me oh yeah I did cool it's like
sabber puny thanks for creating this league it's
pretty concept yes it is it seems our dear Ramona
has a new Suitor it's really happening who is he
oh Scott Pilgrim awesome 23 years old wow jobless
hopeless he's in an indie band of subjective
quality hey hey that's great they've been on
one date but he's currently sleeping in her
bed that bastard Scott Pilgrim is dating a high
schooler uh uhoh wait I I'm sorry interesting way
to present it they did hold hands once okay does
Ramona know still odd what's his fight experience
he's been described as quote the best fighter in
the province unot by who I'll relish this Victory
Ramona's new guy's going to wish he was never
born oh wow is this fun because of me because
I'm going to kill him and then he'll be dead is
the final few days of his precious little life
yep what time is it not quite 8 a.m. I have
to work I really feel like this is excellently
executed in such a way where you don't need to
have seen the movie or the comics or you could
just be a brand newcomer either way you were
first introduced to this world it'll make you
appreciate it I like the restructuring it
hits on a completely different way my band
has a show tonight you have a band uh oh we're
terrible please come 900 p.m. the rocket I'll
be there uhoh and you know who else going to
be there honest sees oh no you need to break
up with your fake high school girlfriend do
I have to I mean knives is an angel you need
to end it immediately knives is an angel I
challenge you to a blah blah blah something
about fighting [Music] League of evil AES
more like a league of B [Music] ring rocket
rocket whoa lowkey kind of like
the DARE video I am 16 kinds of
pump to see sex bomb tonight I feel so
excited I might actually pass out oh
God boy sure seems like nobody
delivered crushing news to you
today you're better than him just
know that okay better than who these
like 3D holographic effects are so interesting
yeah eyes are literally popping out of its so
I I have to go oh nice perspective the opening
band pulled out they flaked crashing employ flaked
uhoh you can't call A Band Crash crash is a cold
classic car crash sex film shot right here in
Toronto coronin BG if we suck then the audience
won't like us they'll think we [Laughter] suck
this delivery is great there's only one way to
find out if we suck and that's by playing just
open for yourselves you know I love the movie
but I actually feel like everyone's more likable
already yeah and everyone's yeah got just a little
bit more of an approachability or something
that's a great would have put it I'm kind
of seeing someone in the band that's [Music]
crazy I am too who are you dating in the band
[Music] yep I think it helps
too they actually look like
kids oh
Mr Pilgrim and the
boys
awesome he's so dreamy why are we fighting
aren't you Scott Pilgrim depends who's asking it
is Matthew Patel Ramona's first evil ex-boyfriend
uh-oh didn't you read my letter kind of
I hand delivered it during a blizzard
a I had delivered itard flowers has seven
evil exes all of whom you must defeat in
order to date her my God they're like
demonic entities there's definitely some
Jamie huet in this in the inspiration
and you really dated this guy in middle
school for some reason all the
little jocks wanted me Matthew
Patel was the only non-white non jock boy in
school nothing could beat Matthew's
mystical Powers combined with my brute
strength woof he didn't even get truly
evil until high school and by that time
he lived Far Far Away simmering all's
fair in love and uh war time to fight
I love his super dry H response round
one oh waa it's like an actual Street
[Applause]
Fighter
Zach that
it oh okay I
one I won believe in yourself man you're on a
league whoa cool yo that was awesome yeah I
really thought that was fantastic very much
so I I love the Contra I mean I love how it
complement and contrasts with the movie and
brings at least the vague amount I'm familiar
with from The Source material to to life and
then brings its own style on top of that you know
yeah man I thought the animation was great I love
me some animated properties you know sometimes I
look at our shirts like and I go wow what you can
do when you combine liveaction with animated
counterpart part www. reation shop.com you
get shirts like the shop Protection Services one
right here hey or the classic movie tickets there
you go or space babies of the G who influences
The influencers Watchman inspired a soda a soda
snip snip dude the characters on this show would
wear all of these T-shirts they really would wear
all these t-shirts as should you cuz it is the
best way to support the channel ding my favorite
way personally so thank you to all thank you
seriously to everyone who has bought a shirt
because I think you will feel very I they're also
very comfortable that's thing I really want to
emphasize they're extremely comfortable shirts
and that's why even before having this shop uh
I would always alternate between the same kind
of shirts because I I prioritize comfort more
than anything else and so yeah when crafting
the shirts you know you went to factories all
over the world Tred around fac yeah yeah this one
little children in sh yes until we finally found
one in the Himalayas who made the perfect softness
and stretchability th he just hooked up to tubes
most of his limbs been retrofitted with Machinery
we've removed a pain sensor in his brain he's a
husk now leading for a merchandising husk um on
a lighter note on a lighter note uh I did think
this was a very impressive ethereal experience
that had such a softer Hue about the whole tone
to it cuz yeah it's like you expect that what
from just knowing the liveaction uh counterpart
part where it's already very expressive and
you're like wow look at all these like video
game and Anime influences when you're watching
the liveaction one you'd only expect it to go
kind of more Bonkers with it its expression yet I
actually feel like Pace wise and tonal wise they
dialed some of that back so you actually get a
great balance otherwise this just could have been
an over stimulating experience and maybe they're
gonna get crazier as it goes I don't really know
but what was fun was watching okay yeah like uh
some stuff we've seen in the live action because
live action's adap adapting the know it's pretty
faithful from what I understand to the parts of
the novels that it's adapting yeah but you got to
find a structure within a movie yeah and and and
condense things and yeah so versus here where
some stuff might feel like oh this is coming a
lot earlier than maybe I was expecting it to come
but then it surprises you with oh we're cutting to
this origin of things and like seeing Gideon very
early on or getting the introduction of the league
it and it's fun seeing the surprises and how they
they sort of let it unfold and it's like I like
watching the contrasting differences too between
Scott's world where he does feel more innocent I I
think that is one of the biggest critiques I think
of the film experience is Scott seems like a very
unlikable guy it is a real journey to him becoming
yeah a more soft likable character yeah it's like
the world of Scott pil it's like he's you like him
because he's funny um but he's very much immature
and needs to come of Age and and be humble and he
seems like an [__] and maybe he'll become more
of an [__] as it goes but hear him like this
seems like a sweet kid he probably making some
like not so great I mean he's 23 but he seems like
a kid you know yeah he seems a little more a bit
more innocent in the precariousness that he finds
himself in absolutely um but I thought this was a
a beautiful experience and I love I love like the
visual language of how it differs in so many ways
than what I was expecting like there's a lot of
these like downward shots that really emphasize
how much larger than life a lot of this is like a
lot of the camera comes from the below yeah yeah
yeah looking up at various things and really
kind of enhancing perspectives and stuff like
that like yeah it's funny this is going to be
like the most expanding experience because once
all this visual you know moving media is done I
will finally read you know the the the stories
but but it makes me want to go read the Manga
uh comic but you know I don't know I don't know
which terminology we accept for where it was
published but yeah but yeah it really nicely
contrasts and I think you said that thing about
the movie uh I can't remember exactly what you
said but but you you drew a comparison that that
this being animation almost normalizes some of
the more stylized elements and makes it feel more
breathable anyway and I think that that some of it
is them deliberately making something that has a
more gradual Airy tone and and just in this format
that's kind of striking to me because I feel
like this is bringing the slice of liess about
this and the sort of malays of just being in the
age group these people are and and you know the
concerns that they have uh and and that provides a
nice contrast so that when the more anime specific
flourishes and the video game ones too kick in
like they're you know especially kind of bright
and captivating and I think the movie it's weird
it's like they're both using anime and video game
stylization as part of the fun of their style but
there is something that does feel different this
iteration of that than the movie and I feel like
where the movie maybe while it has a lot of anime
stuff kind of leans a bit more video game to me
I feel like this will then lean a bit more anime
and have the video game stuff be a bit more of
a garnish well the other one really felt the the
live action feels still like an edar right movie
yeah this does not feel like an edar right show
it doesn't feel like a watching yeah but that but
in a good way because you because right was taking
inspiration from something and then I'm sure
like he's got fingerprints and his DNA in here
still yeah where it's here I'm just absorbing
the world because the writing feels different
the the the execution feels different and Beyond
just hey we're looking at an animated versus a
liveaction the actual execution of the story it's
it's like when you watch like a different type of
restructuring placement of events where you choose
to put your focus like even by this point in in
not I I look it's it's a r it's it's some people
might get annoyed by the amount of like kind of
comparing to the movie but I think there's going
to be millions of millions of people across the
world doing it right now it's fun contrasting
going it's not the it's not the movie and I'm
mad it's different when you're like oh this is
cool that they complement and contrast each other
yeah yeah and and like you said it is actually
making me want to read uh the an the actual Source
material because looking at this I it makes me go
oh how how different is it and and I like watching
these differences unfold like I think the voice
actors are are great so much to the point where
I'm not hearing a celebrity talking which is what
I thought the characters I thought that's what it
would feel like yeah but I think that's the nice
primer is like you have this sort of sense memory
in the back of your mind of like I've heard all
these people be these characters before but then
yeah it is so animation feel different though
yeah and I a beautiful thing and edite isn't
involved in this but I think it is a beautiful
thing about letting you know I'm sure Brian leoi
he's he's you know the credited he's clearly
writing and authoring and co-writing these and
and heavily you know involved with the authorship
and whoever the directors are as well like I think
it's again it makes me want to go back to the
source material and see how before I lose this
thought I have to interrupt you I think I know
what what feels different about it I think the
movie the biggest voice about that movie is the
style yes and here I'm actually really feeling all
the emotional undertones no 100% yeah yeah yeah
it's like there there is that stuff but the movie
is really dazzling you and it's also like breaking
ground for a bunch of other things quirky and fast
and and but here I'm like oh I'm really feeling
the emotion and I I don't quite think of that when
I think of the movie yeah you know it just lets
you sit in the space and it takes time for these
interludes and even though it is compact it's
not that long like I think the the full kind of
27 28 minute experience allows you to have these
interludes that are quite beautiful like when they
they they're they have things that are fleeting
but very beautiful when they're in the park
together and then you know that leads up it's like
a nice just back and forth scene and it's very
beautiful but kind of sparse and then they take
the you know space tunnel back to her house and
even the scene between them in the house yeah you
just you kind of feel the cold and you feel you
know the kind of want for the warmth of the bed
and the warmth of intimacy and yeah it's like it's
fascinating to think of those things and now I'm
curious to to go and look and see okay so how did
the source material represent this emotionality
and how did it represent the stylized homages to
all the pop culture stuff that we love well you
said warmth because yeah like saying feeling the
warmth I'm like well actually emotionally that's
I feel the heart I feel the warmth of these
characters more even though you know some of the
more I'm sure the [__] resides will come through
right now I I I'm I'm endeared to the characters
and not in a way where I'm just kind of observing
and really enjoying and giddy like I'm it's it's
strange and I thought it would be the antithesis
I thought this would be way more style like like
a fun sugar rush but what I've left with now is
like the tonality and the and the the atmosphere
and the feeling of it it's weird it's like this
has you even this is more I this is not a slight
whatsoever but in a way you could kind of just
like put this on and chill to this you and there
is something also too about the combination of
the voices and the animation because the animation
like I am kind of endeared and impressed by only
in that I guess in you know we live in a world
with like stuff like what if which I really like
uh in lots of ways but you know that's clearly
like computer animated with some nods to what
handrawn stuff looks like whereas I don't know I
guess something that's produced by Netflix here
I'm a little bit like are they going to go full
on with how the animation production values are
presented and here I don't know I mean this could
all be done in a computer it probably is but this
has the look and feel at least to me of something
that has that handdrawn anime tangibility to it
and I think the modern ways in which they you you
mentioned the stereos scoping like the way they
represent depth of field and and camera glass and
stuff like that that through these stylized things
especially in like a post spiderverse world is
like really lovely and this is reminding me of
like other graphic novels or other animation not
wholesale but just in the way that they feel kind
of tangible and not like the exact aesthetic it's
nice because this Harkens to anime has a lot of
the you know uh uh color and Line work that evokes
that but this also has the benefit of the book's
art style which is inspired by that but is also
kind of adapting that you know kind of colliding
it I feel like I don't know exactly but I feel
like the anime is Brian Le Ali like is in America
right like he's not like in Japan I don't know
but I always he sounds Japanese it's it it feels
like well you know he's he's he sounds like a guy
who comes from a mixed background and certainly
this is about you know like Canadians hanging
out in Canada so there there feels like a kind
of melding of traditions in terms of the animation
that is certainly skewing way more anime but yeah
it has something that's that seems concerned with
the art being kind of beautiful and ethereal also
well I I felt like there was a little bit more in
the live action a little bit more entitlement and
snobbery in some of their characters and here what
I thought was neat is talk about the characters me
sound like I don't like they're a little more edgy
yeah um but there a bit more of a cnic cynicism to
the approach of the characters I would say um and
and the world of the characters and that and that
supports the whip crack tone yeah yeah yeah the
contrast of that but the what was cool about the
structure here of introducing the league he you
need that for a show cuz like in the movie it's
it's like a surprise like whoa this came out of
nowhere and it's a surprise and then the action
happens you're like what the hell like this
is and it's supposed to have that effect and I
think what was different about the vibe here is a
not going through knives Chow uh so early on yeah
and and letting you just get so acquainted with
like man he's a dick in this relationship and so
you're just you're just connected to the romance
to henra Ramona and then having the introduction
of the villains or the tease of them which does
feel like anime demonic kind of villainy with
the evil and the eyes and stuff but what's really
cool about that is then you have a threat to the
relationship yeah as opposed to just a fun game
you're going to go through well yeah you've got
the compounding of like oh the stakes are already
high cuz they're both here and now we're going
to get multiple reveals you know because her
Ramona's pass is going to be revealed to some
extent and also I mean you know Scott is Small
Change on the floor right now so you know that
kniv is gonna have something to say about that
I didn't think we'd have so much to say about
the first episode I thought we'd have to like kind
of settle with it but hey we got uh seven more of
these to go through uh but I'm I'm on board for
the journey man I'm on board for the journey uh
that took me by surprise in a way I really wasn't
expecting yeah this this this like I thought it
was just going to be like fun this fed me more
than like you know like I'm already excited and
I'm already like inclined towards liking it
and this engaged me well beyond that in ways
I wasn't expecting it to along with all the the
stuff I understand to be the earmarks of this so
like I'm I'm just surprised that yeah it's like
especially because Netflix is getting into making
more anime I'm like this actually gives me a lot
of Hope for that % th% feels really crafted and
that's beautiful all right guys well what did
you think about this um I'm sure you guys are
already done with the series if you're watching
this reaction uh but let us know your thoughts
down in the comments and uh keep a lookout for
our reaction to uh episode dose uh we'll try to
get these out every other day hopefully we have
holidays coming up so please be patient if we uh
fall behind a little bit on schedule but thank
you so much we'll talk with you all [Music] soon